[Música]
el eje Franco alemán parece estar
tomando distancia esos años en que París
y Berlín lideraban a toda velocidad esa
integración Europea el desarrollo
económico y también el peso y el
liderazgo de la Unión Europea en el
mundo parecen haber quedado atrás por el
momento esta era de la pospandemia del
covid 19 la influencia de Donald Trump
como presidente de Estados Unidos
también el brexit y la invasión de Rusia
a Ucrania y así como el fin de La era de
Ángela Merkel como canciller de Alemania
Tal parece que representa un cierre de
un capítulo y el inicio de otro en el
que a Berlín y a París les está costando
un poco más complementarse y sobre todo
articularse eso mientras en el resto de
la Unión Europea le siguen reclamando
ambos países liderazgo Entonces está el
eje Franco alemán enfriándose alejándose
y que representa esto este alejamiento
en el contexto de la guerra en Europa y
en la crisis energética actual que
representa esto para el bloque de los
2017 pues para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a Luis Carlos Olivares se les
economista de abogado especialista en
análisis de políticas públicas para el
desarrollo él se encuentra en la ciudad
de San José de la capital de Costa Rica
y desde Alemania se conecta johannchmidt
él es politólogo investigador de la
Universidad Católica de einstad
ingorstad y también les recuerdo a
nuestros televidentes que son parte de
este debate pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram ustedes ya lo
saben
@ el
debate_f24@santilogo y la etiqueta para
que ustedes puedan dejar todos los
comentarios se las recuerdo numeral el
debate f24 todo junto no olviden también
que todos los contenidos de este
programa también están disponibles en de
plataformas de podcast estamos en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
le doy la bienvenida entonces a Luis
Carlos en la ciudad de San José y para
conocer su opinión Luis Carlos
Bienvenido al programa están desde su
análisis Francia de Alemania
verdaderamente alejándose
Muchas gracias y muy raro estar en su
programa A mi modo de ver creo que las
preocupaciones que resultan graves para
algunas personas tienen razón de ser por
ejemplo podemos ver en retrospectiva que
desde el 63
las cumbres que se han celebrado de
manera binacional no habían sido ni
aplazadas ni canceladas esto por
supuesto que despierta todas las
susceptibilidades de los de los
analistas Y por supuesto
susceptibilidades que le son propias a
los mercados internacionales entonces
Desde esa perspectiva los nervios que
está generando un tipo
este gesto este el simbolismo que genera
que se genera alrededor de esta de este
gesto en cuanto a las relaciones
binacionales entre Francia y Alemania no
deja de tornarse con cierta gravedad O
al menos demanda cierta atención de
parte del resto del mundo desde la
perspectiva de las relaciones económicas
de estos dos países
pues ellas Claro está que resultan
fundamentales para la Unión Europea como
bien se mencionaba la el liderazgo de
Francia y Alemania como las dos grandes
economías poseedoras de algunos de los
motores industriales de Europa más
importantes y además siendo dos de los
mercados de llegada más relevantes en el
ámbito de la Unión Europea
suscitan uno menos que ciertas como
decía anteriormente susceptibilidades en
los mercados internacionales justamente
la envergadura de la demanda de estos
dos países como mercados de llegada como
output genera esa susceptibilidades Y
por supuesto que viene al traste o
deviene en en estos cuestionamientos a
propósito de las relaciones bilaterales
entre Francia y Alemania sí relaciones
que deben ser
solucionadas o al menos desaveniencias o
disonancias que deben ser puestas sobre
la mesa y aclaradas lo antes posible
porque la coyuntura actual es
geopolítica y económica demanda no menos
acciones claras Y asertivas de parte de
todo de estos países la ve la palabra
ahora a nuestro siguiente invitado Johan
clansmith en Alemania bienvenido también
doctor clan Smith Gracias por estar con
nosotros y su opinión están
verdaderamente desde su análisis Francia
de Alemania
distanciandose alejándose un poco
bueno Alejandro sé un poco en la
coyuntura en el momento no significa que
no habrá relaciones importantes y en
realidad Si siguen siendo gemelos siguen
estando muy cercanos en su posición como
países democráticos industrializados
vecinos en la Unión Europea en la otan
pero básicamente dos tendencias dos
coyunturas están
Están causando turbulencias no la
primera es la poca experiencia y la poca
coordinación que ejerce o la shorts el
nuevo canciller en la política exterior
de Alemania
Merkel tenía un estilo muy coordinador
muy orientado hacia el consenso con
especialmente Francia y
consultaba con Emmanuel macrón antes de
importantes decisiones etcétera etcétera
shorts todavía tiene un estilo mucho más
ejecutivo mucho más desde su experiencia
de ministro de hacienda se está
coordinando sobre todo con su propio
partido político también muy poco con su
con su ministra de relaciones exteriores
que es de otro partido y
así ha surgido también dentro de
Alemania una crítica muy fuerte contra
el estilo de shorts en la política
exterior de Alemania una gran mayoría de
los alemanes dicen que parece abrumado
por la por los múltiples desafíos
la segunda tendencia es que simplemente
en Europa están emergiendo otros centros
no tanto de poder material clásico pero
que simplemente están más cercanos
geográficamente a amenazas como la
agresión rusa en Ucrania como los países
de Europa
Oriental que tienen más atención que que
se están coordinando mejor que tienen
menos peso en términos económicos pero
que sí tienen un mayor interés en este
momento en coordinarse y por eso están
desplazando un poco a los centros
tradicionales de la política europea yo
continuó con usted allí en Alemania
usted menciona dos puntos importantes el
surgimiento de estos centros de poder en
otros puntos de Europa y también esa la
forma en que el canciller shorts ha
llevado Alemania a lo largo de de este
bueno los pocos meses que todavía lleva
como canciller y habiendo Angela Merkel
dejando dejado un listón muy alto en
cuanto al liderazgo europeo y al
liderazgo de Alemania entonces de
acuerdo a ese análisis que usted hace
Cómo repercute esto en la toma de
decisiones de la Unión Europea y en la
no toma de decisiones y en la rapidez
que tiene que ponerse se despertó el
bloque de los 27 para tomar decisiones
importantes Como por ejemplo frente a la
situación con Ucrania
Bueno
un punto importante es obviamente la
decisión unilateral de Alemania de hacer
un paquete de 200 mil millones de euros
para controlar los precios de los
combustibles y de la energía sin
Consultar con sus aliados sin Consultar
con los otros países miembros de la
Unión Europea la coordinación económica
siempre ha sido un punto difícil de las
relaciones Franco alemanas ahí pueden
ver el reporte de la comisión
a otros países en la Unión Europea les
hubiera gustado no solo a Francia No
únicamente a Francia que Alemania se
coordina más que que no tome medidas
unilaterales que pueden causar problemas
que pueden causar escasez Incluso en
términos energéticos para otros miembros
de la Unión Europea Así que un poco más
de coordinación un poco más de
solidaridad
hubiera sido
en orden no y se está fortaleciendo esa
imagen de Alemania que toma medidas sin
realmente considerar a sus vecinos a sus
amigos claro aliados como ya lo hizo en
la crisis con Ucrania y son decisiones
que muchas veces requieren un músculo
económico que lo puede hacer Alemania
porque es el motor económico de la Unión
Europea y otros Perdón otros países no
lo pueden hacer pero le doy la palabra
ahora a Luis Carlos para preguntarle
ponernos en contexto para este lado del
Atlántico aquí en América Latina en
donde no estamos muy familiarizados con
la política de la Unión Europea porque
es tan trascendental que París y Berlín
estén de acuerdo en esta toma de
decisiones cuando por ejemplo está
Bruselas que es la sede de la Unión
Europea y cuando también hay una
presidencia rotativa de la Unión Europea
que en este momento la lleva la
República Checa está en manos del
gobierno en Praga Porque hay tanta
presión y tanta expectativa en torno a
la relación París Berlín
bueno es importante de diversas aristas
una de las principales es la lista
económica por ejemplo ya bien se
mencionaba anteriormente de que el
gobierno alemán y de hecho estas
acusaciones o estos señalamientos
provienen de Francia lo que diría a
continuación el plan de 200 mil millones
de euros para proteger a los hogares Y
las empresas de su país
ha suscitado cierto dejo de presión de
varios socios de la Unión Europea Desde
esa perspectiva o las actuaciones
unívocas que se puedan tomar en el seno
de la Unión Europea Por supuesto que
tienen implicaciones e implicaciones en
virtud de las relaciones de
interdependencia compleja que se generan
en este mundo globalizado con respecto
no sólo al entorno de la Unión Europea
sino con respecto al resto del mundo
occidente incluso para nuestros
intereses en América Latina tan es así
que por ejemplo no en pocas ocasiones se
ha la decisión o la decisión que surge
acerca de impulsar el plan de ayuda a
unívoco alemán surge frente a la
ejecutiva de que esto pueda generar
problemas para los consumidores internos
y esto pueda generar una oleada más
profunda más onda para el resto de los
países una oleada inflacionaria que
viene a raíz del contagio de los precios
de los productos energéticos Entonces
como bien puede ver a raíz de este
ejemplo las decisiones que se puedan dar
en el seno de la Unión Europea Por
supuesto que van a tener un impacto
grandísimo en el resto de del mundo de
occidente y de nuestra América Latina
siempre adoleciendo de cierto dejo de
vulnerabilidad frente a estas decisiones
Desde esa perspectiva la coherencia que
pueda existir en las decisiones
políticas que se puedan tomar en el seno
de la Unión Europea Por supuesto que
tiene repercusiones y tiene Ecos
gravísimos sobre el resto de nuestros
países sobre todo si lo consideramos en
perspectiva de que estamos viviendo una
coyuntura de
especialísima atención de franca
excepcionalidad que debemos aunar el
alcohol a las crisis de los contenedores
y a la crisis energética desde efectiva
debemos tener cuidado con las decisiones
que puedan tomarse de manera unívoca y
la vinculación que pueda existir con los
mercados interdependientes
complementamos el análisis con la
opinión de ellos en Alemania sobre la
importancia de la relación Berlín París
Porque hay tanta presión sobre ellos
cuando está Bruselas que es la sede de
la Unión Europea que es donde se verían
de tomar las decisiones y por qué
Bruselas también nos llama un poco al
orden a Alemania en cuanto a esta toma
de decisiones que ha hecho sin
consultarle a los otros países
integrantes de la Unión Europea
creo que es importante entender que no
existe una jerarquía estricta entre
Bruselas y las capitales nacionales
dentro de la Unión Europea no no se
trata de un hiperestado o algo así no
Así que Bruselas siempre necesitará la
cooperación de los miembros importantes
de la Unión Europea y
tradicionalmente eso han sido
frecuentemente Alemania y Francia aunque
no deberíamos equivocarnos siempre
también han existido importantes
diferencias entre Francia y Alemania con
respecto a al mantenimiento de la
soberanía nacional con respecto a la
liberalización de políticas económicas
etcétera etcétera y en realidad Entonces
lo importante no es tanto que haya un
consenso Perpetuo absoluto entre París y
Berlín pero que que haya un estilo un
poco más coordinador un estilo un poco
más coordinado más comunicativo más
solidario desde el gobierno de olafolls
tengo la impresión que en estos días se
está generando un choque sobre la mala
recepción de la política exterior de
tanto internamente como externamente y
es posible que esto todavía son los
primeros pasos de un gobierno que ha
estado en modo de reaccionar a crisis
unilateralmente básicamente desde su
primer día
Luis Carlos hay tres escenarios que
llaman la atención y uno es el brexit
que marcó el retiro del Reino Unido de
la Unión Europea también el fin de La
era de Ángela Merkel en Alemania y la
situación económica que se está
presentando no solamente en Europa sino
en el mundo entero Estos son
digamos
factores que están provocando o están
dejando en evidencia una crisis de
Liderazgo al interior de la Unión
Europea que se han venido acumulando
estos diferentes hechos y ahora digamos
que está dejando en evidencia y bueno
también puedo sumar ese surgimiento de
de gobierno gobiernos de derecha y de
ultraderecha en algunos países en el
este de Europa que son digamos países un
poco más contestatarios ahora a hacia
Bruselas Esto está dejando en evidencia
una crisis de Liderazgo al interior del
bloque
que mejor para evidenciar
dudas acerca de los liderazgos que
puedan generarse en los distintos
estados que la necesidad de atender a
razones de urgencia de carácter
económico Desde esa perspectiva yo creo
que los factores que ya habían ha
mencionado se deben aunar al hecho de
que y vienen en detrimento de lo
anterior el hecho de que tengamos en
ciernes aún y no hayamos escapado de
ello en el mundo la crisis económica del
covid la crisis de los contenedores Y
por supuesto que en virtud de estas
condiciones el juego político que existe
en virtud de los poderes que se gestan a
raíz de las relaciones de
interdependencia podemos ver cómo se
suscitan o cómo se integran nuevos
poderes en las relaciones este en las
relaciones internacionales vemos por
ejemplo que a raíz de la necesidad
económica que hay para suplir la matriz
energética en Europa han debido recurrir
a ciertas a cierta demanda o cierta
capacidad por ejemplo del gobierno del
gobierno chino Asimismo ha entrado al
juego por ejemplo occidente Estados
Unidos y la nueva política de biden
Nueva política monetaria los nuevos
llamados a los liderazgos de la Unión
Europea entonces Desde esa perspectiva
toda esta batería de razones se conjugan
para generar en primer lugar una crisis
de liderazgos que puede ser vista en
razón de la actual incapacidad que que
ha habido de respuesta de parte de los
gobiernos en la Unión Europea para
atender de manera sólida y de manera
conjunta presentando un flanco común
como respuesta a la crisis de Rusia y y
de Ucrania y entonces Desde esa
perspectiva la laceración que ha habido
y la erosión de los liderazgos que se
han generado en la Unión Europea Por
supuesto que se ve aderezada por
anteriores factores y anteriores causas
como usted bien mencionaba que es el
brexit en el juego político no debemos
de desdeñar del Análisis económico que
debemos hacer en virtud de El potencial
económico que podrían tener estos
gobiernos en razón de una actuación
conjunta Desde esa perspectiva Insisto
que mejor para ver una crisis de
Liderazgo que la necesidad de atender a
razones económicas de carácter de
urgencia su opinión
estoy de acuerdo Estoy totalmente de
acuerdo y en realidad también hay que
tomar en cuenta que hubo en los últimos
años cuando hubo problemas como Trump
como brexit en los países anglosajones
etcétera no
hubo la percepción que Alemania Era ese
país muy estable muy responsable y en
realidad entre expertos y hubo críticas
muy duras por ejemplo de las políticas
energéticas del gobierno de Merkel con
su exagerada dependencia de Rusia en
materias de
recursos energéticos y en realidad todos
esos problemas que muchos expertos ya
vieron llegando ahora se están ahora
están tocando a la misma vez generando
una grave crisis de confidencia sobre
todo en Alemania de Francia nadie es
Nadie estaba esperando que la política o
economía de Francia iba a ser perfecta
pero Alemania tenía esa imagen de
algunos dijeron que Ángela Merkel era la
lideresa del mundo libre eso siempre era
pues ridículo En mi opinión no Alemania
ya tenía muchos problemas y ahora están
llegando a cobrar
la Unión Europea extraña a Ángela Merkel
pese a los a la complicación que se está
presentando en este momento muchos dicen
que era justamente Merkel la que había
frenado el escenario de una invasión a
Ucrania precisamente porque le hablaba
directamente al presidente Putin y sin
ser amigos tener una relación estrecha y
por lo menos Putin respetaba y escuchaba
lo que decía Ángela Merkel Europa
extraña a Merkel y extraña ese liderazgo
que tal vez sholes y macron no han
podido asumir
en realidad yo diría que no muchas de
las políticas de Ángela Merkel
contribuyeron a esas problemáticas no y
es verdad que posiblemente respetaba
Ángela la escuchaba Pero al final esa
guerra contra Ucrania básicamente ya
empezó en el 2014 y
si marque él estuviera en la posición de
shorts hoy en día no creo que haría algo
mucho mejor Con respecto a la
confrontación con Rusia haría en mi
opinión más o menos lo mismo y Putin en
realidad tampoco es el estratégico
racional lógico que todos pensaban Pero
vive ya en su propio universo
conspiranoico y va a seguir a
imperativos que vienen de ese mundo y no
de lo que opinan los líderes de Europa
occidental
nadie ha podido argumentar racionalmente
con Vladimir Putin claro y
solo hay que esperar la derrota militar
convencional de las fuerzas rusas en
Ucrania y entonces se va a solucionar
esa situación y lo que deberían hacer
los líderes de Europa occidentales
contribuir mucho más en términos de
armas pesadas municiones etcétera
etcétera A esa derrota Para volver la
estabilidad estratégica al continente
europeo Luis Carlos su opinión sobre
esta falta de liderazgo en Europa y tal
vez está ausencia de Merkel que algunos
sectores pueden extrañar o no usted que
analiza de este tema
yo coincido en el siguiente sentido
coincido en que difícilmente uno podría
haber dilucidado algunas decisiones que
hubiese tomado estando Merkel desde el
punto de vista de Alemania pero la
crisis o la posible crisis de Liderazgo
se ve agravada sobre todo en razón de
los retos que vienen posteriormente
tenemos que ver que existen nuevas
oportunidades para la generación de
zonas de influencia También las
actuaciones unívocas de parte de parte
de Alemania por ejemplo ya alcanciller
alemán schools ha pedido un Plan
Marshall del Siglo 21 para la
reconstrucción de Ucrania y esto ya
pensando en términos posteriores a la
actuación
posguerra pues post invasión Entonces
estamos viendo que en el mundo se
suscitan necesidades y retos y demandas
importantísimas como para tener estas
decisiones tan graves desde desde el
punto de vista de los liderazgos lo que
es importante acá es que occidente
genere un frente como un flanco común
que genera actuaciones en perspectiva
económica que sean comunes para poder
hacer un freno y contrapeso a las
actuaciones arbitrarias que vienen de
Rusia y que por supuesto están afectando
al resto del mundo así lo demanda
las necesidades económicas del mundo
actual Y por supuesto que políticas Más
allá del liderazgo sunívocos yo
apostaría en particular y así lo creo
humildemente apostaría por la generación
de un Franco común de un de una
vertiente común de los países
occidentales que pueda reconstituir La
balanza de frenos y contrapesos frente
al poder arbitrario de Rusia Luis Carlos
y mientras esto sucede mientras este
escenario que es factible tiene lugar
quienes están aprovechando precisamente
esta falta de liderazgo en la Unión
Europea y esta falta de entendimiento o
digamos comunicación fluida porque la
relación se mantiene los dos países se
mantienen cercanos pero esa falta la
fluidez en la relación entre Berlín y
París quienes están aprovechando esta
coyuntura entre esos dos países para
tomar ventaja de la situación
bueno deberíamos definir provecho si
estamos pensando en el provecho
económico Por supuesto que hay actores
mundiales que claramente están sacando
excesivas rentas de los precios
inflacionarios que están pagando los
consumidores finales en todo el mundo
hablemos por ejemplo del oligopolio del
petróleo de medio oriente en donde en
virtud de ese poder oligopólico se están
fijando algunos precios a pesar de que
Estados Unidos ya ha salido a la
delantera a mencionar que debería
existir un tope del crecimiento de los
precios sin embargo también las
las intentonas que se han hecho de parte
de parte de Alemania al aumentar la
oferta en el mercado mundial no han sido
totalmente exitosas para la producción
de los precios desde esa perspectiva
quienes ostentan el poder monopólico de
Mercado en el mundo están generando un
aprovechamiento de carácter económico
que les permite vincularse con mayores
relaciones de dependencia frente a los
poderes políticos europeos Asimismo en
razón de la dependencia que puedes que
existe que en efecto existe y que es
estacional de parte de los países de
Europa sobre las necesidades energéticas
Por supuesto que han tenido que volver a
ver a China desde esa perspectiva el
posicionamiento y el aprovechamiento
económico al tener un nuevo mercado de
llegada Por supuesto que está
fortaleciendo las rentas que está
aprovechando en razón de una depende de
una de una demanda que es absolutamente
elástica a los diversos niveles de
precios porque es una necesidad fácil y
la ve la palabra ayojen quienes pueden
estar aprovechando de esta coyuntura y
le pregunto y le pongo algunas cartas
sobre la mesa el Reino Unido estos
gobiernos de derecha que han llegado a
Italia que están gobernando ahora en
Hungría incluso Turquía que era un país
candidato a la Unión Europea Quién es
más están aprovechando eso
bueno no son en realidad esos gobiernos
populistas de orbán o de erdon erdon
tiene sus propios problemas económicos
como un país recientemente
industrializado con muchos problemas de
productividad
y de dependencia de recursos energéticos
de otros países
no veo que sea Turquía Hungría está
enfrentando un aislamiento grave dentro
de la Unión Europea porque desde la
situación pues desde la invasión de
Rusia en Ucrania
también Polonia que anteriormente apoyó
a Hungría que anteriormente salvó a un
cría de las sanciones de la Unión
Europea está contribuyendo al
aislamiento de orban dentro de la unión
así que qué más Gran Bretaña tiene una
crisis grave de efectividad institu
personal con cambios de gobiernos esta
imprevisible cuánto tiempo se va a
quedar el nuevo gobierno está
imprevisible que va a suceder en
términos de la estabilidad financiera de
la libra esterlina
real nadie en realidad es un mundo como
dice es un mundo g0 donde no hay las
grandes potencias que podrían ejercer
una influencia hegemónica todos países
en el mundo están más preocupados por su
estabilidad interna y por su viabilidad
económica y ecológica y bueno un país
Rusia escogió la agresión externa para
enfrentar esas dudas y estamos viendo el
resultado desastroso Claro pero no en
realidad no veo que eso sea un
un asunto de la distribución de poder
internacional es mucho más un problema
de entropía social en diferentes lugares
también en ese orden de ideas jorgen
usted que se encuentra en Alemania
Alemania estaría poniendo fin a un
capítulo de su historia en donde se ve
como el gigante económico de la zona
Euro el gigante económico de Europa un
modelo que funcionó durante muchos años
a través de comprar gas y petróleo muy
barato a Rusia a ser muy poca inversión
en temas militares por ejemplo pero sí
apostándole mucho al desarrollo social
al desarrollo
económico pero tampoco mucho en el en el
en el Tecnológico sabemos el atraso que
tiene Alemania en algunos procesos
digitales frente a otros países de la
Unión Europea Entonces es el momento en
que Alemania va a tener que cambiar
modificar ese modelo rápidamente para
poder seguir manteniéndose como una
económica dentro de la Unión
absolutamente absolutamente están
circulando aquí historias sobre cómo los
refugiados ucranianos se están quejando
sobre la mala calidad la mala conexión
del internet en Alemania y los trenes
del ferrocarril ucraniano ya tienen
conexión de internet también en
conexiones cortas etcétera etcétera Así
que realmente la baja inversión en
infraestructura en términos de
tecnología el bajo nivel de
digitalización en la administración
pública en también en algunas empresas
son temas que están están en la
conciencia pública están siendo muy
criticados pero todavía necesita mucho
trabajo necesita muchísima inversión y
necesita sobre todo caminos más directos
a las a las soluciones tecnocráticas que
están faltando en este momento Alemania
Y ante eso dependen también los socios
dentro de la Unión Europea quienes
dependen de la viabilidad industrial y
económica de Alemania
Luis Carlos Si uno mira el mapa de la
Unión Europea lo hemos mencionado acá
Alemania siempre se destacó por su tema
económico mencionábamos hace unos
minutos esa baja inversión en temas
militares lo contrario sucede en Francia
que es un país que a nivel militar era
destacado dentro del bloque europeo
junto con el Reino Unido era
prácticamente se puede decir uno de los
ejércitos y de las fuerzas militares
mejor armadas de toda la Unión Europea y
en el contexto de la guerra Berlín ha
propuesto un proyecto de un escudo
antimisiles europeo junto con otros 14
países de la unión y Francia ha dicho
que no quiere participar que no quiere
fomentar una carrera armamentística en
el en el bloque y mucho menos en el
Continente teniendo a Rusia de vecino
pero en realidad Tal parece que aquí la
discrepancia sería porque este bloque
europeo optaría por
armar este escudo con tecnología de
Estados Unidos o de Israel y no
tecnología francesa y ahí es donde París
estaría cobrandole esa factura a ese
liderazgo de Berlín son este tipo de
factores también que se suman Entonces a
esa discrepancia a ese alejamiento y
enfriamiento y donde se olvida Entonces
el interés común
tal cual el problema o el agravante es
que ambas partes estén prefiriendo en
este momento caminar solas por el
momento este parece que ambas partes
prefieren ir por su propio camino como
ya ustedes vienen decía Berlín bueno
aprobó el paquete de ayudas de 200 mil
millones de euros
contra su vida del gas verdad Y esto sin
informar previamente al socio francés
Pero además en la reunión de la otan
Alemania había firmado un proyecto de
defensa aérea conjunta con una docena de
otros países pero sin Francia verdad Y
aunque Francia ya estaba trabajando con
Italia en el escudo antimisiles mamba
Esta es una de las consideraciones en la
Cumbre de jefes de estado y de gobierno
de la Unión Europea macron decía que
junto con España y Portugal y esto
añadiendo otro de los factores digamos a
la batería de problemáticas anuncia
planes para construir un nuevo
gaseoducto para el hidrógeno y si es
necesario para generar o para
transportar gas entre Barcelona y marse
y este proyecto viene a sustituir la
opción que le era más que la era
preferible a Alemania verdad que era los
planes del gaseoso del gaseoducto midka
entre España y Francia a través de los
pirineos estas condiciones así lo dijo
macron en Bruselas no es bueno para para
Alemania y ni para Europa y tampoco es
bueno el resultado de que ambas partes
prefieran o les esté simpatizando aún
más caminar caminar solas el mundo en
términos generales no tiene tiempo para
eso hay una guerra en Europa y nos
enfrentamos a una crisis económica
mundial una crisis energética y estas
decisiones vienen en el peor de los
momentos desde la perspectiva económica
pues llegando al final del programa
quiero hacer las conclusiones sobre lo
que va a pasar qué factura le va a pasar
a estos dos países estar distanciados no
entenderse querer cada uno llevar una
agenda por un lado con intereses muy
distintos en términos energéticos
medioambientales en cuanto al manejo que
se a la a la crisis en Ucrania comienzo
con John en Alemania Cuál es su
conclusión qué podemos ver de esta
relación para los próximos meses siempre
lo digo ya es frase de oro aquí en el
programa no tenemos la bola de cristal
pero que puede uno analizar a futuro
bueno mucho depende de cómo procede la
guerra en Ucrania en los futuros meses
es
no es probable que que que es esa el
apoyo de los países occidentales Pero va
a ser un proceso de años más o vamos a
ver ya el fin acercándose en ese caso
creo que podríamos ver una cooperación
más intensa una cooperación más decidida
para formar el orden político económico
y estratégico de la posguerra no en la
posguerra de ese evento central de
nuestras vidas muy probablemente en la
en la política europea Luis Carlos su
opinión para el cierre su conclusión
Yo creo que el mundo y específicamente
la Unión Europea se beneficia del
mutualismo y de las relaciones de
mutualismo si se me permite hacer el
paralelismo con respecto al estudio de
las relaciones biológicas puede
aprovecharse del mutualismo que siempre
que ha sido histórico entre Francia y
Alemania un mutualismo coincidente en
razón de las relaciones coyunturales y
de las necesidades comunes de estos
países el principal afectado en términos
generales puede ser el mundo por la
corriente inflacionaria Por los
problemas económicos que puedan
suscitarse en razón de la falta de
coordinación de las faltas de Liderazgo
Y por supuesto que en ese sentido
las vinculaciones económicas hacen que
quien sufra Al fin y al cabo sea el
mundo Entonces desde esa perspectiva Y
coincido con esa afirmación debemos
esperar a ver cuál es el devenir de la
guerra y de la invasión de Rusia en
Ucrania sin embargo
una de las condiciones más sensibles o
una de las venas más sensibles es la
avena económica y yo creo que da señas
de Cuál es el devenir y cuál es el ítem
o el camino que van a tomar en virtud de
las necesidades sobrevivientes estos dos
países en el marco de las relaciones de
poder en el en el ámbito europeo pues ya
veremos Entonces cómo es ese escenario
la conclusión que puede llegar después
del fin de la guerra en Ucrania y
también con el inicio oficial del
Invierno allí en Europa a partir del mes
de diciembre cuando hagan frente a la
verdadera situación de la crisis
energética en el bloque de la Unión
Europea ya veremos si esto obliga a
tomar decisiones mucho más rápido y
mucho más en conjunto entre París y
Berlín porque pues por ahora el
escenario apenas está comenzando el
invierno comienza oficialmente a partir
del mes de diciembre Aunque el frío ya
se está haciendo presente allí a Luis
Carlos les agradezco mucho por haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 a todos ustedes Gracias por la
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania guerreros ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan en sintonía de
frases 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]